soyons réalistes les matières plastiques
ne disparaîtront pas de nos tablettes
dans un avenir rapproché
mais les choses bougent trop lentement
peut-être mais ça bouge
plusieurs entreprises font des pas dans
la bonne direction c'est des petits pas
est ce que c'est suffisant ça c'est la
question voici quelques initiatives
agropur a réduit d'un quart de
millimètre l'épaisseur de ses poches de
l'est que rig a délaissé le plastique
multi couches pour un polypropylène
recyclables et des entreprises ont
remplacé le couvercle rigide par un film
plastique souple moins volumineux
parfois c'est le produit lui-même qui
est transformé comme l'expliquent le
directeur du conseil canadien du
commerce de détail
les compagnies de savon à lens on rit du
la grosse alors l'emballage parce qu'ils
ont concentré le produit qui est à
l'intérieur ça coûte moins cher à
transporter que ça prend moins de place
dans les entrepôts donc une meilleure
empreinte sur l'environnement ou sur
notre empreinte
maintenant le fait d'abord pour des
raisons économiques les compagnies ça
leur coûte moins cher de le transporter
c'est ça la première est un ensemble
sont plus réduire nos coûts tant mule
mais on va toujours produire du
plastique avec du pétrole actuellement
oui on en produit beaucoup avec du
pétrole c'est clair mais on veut avoir
un glissement vers des produits dérivés
de produits plastiques biosourcés par
exemple coca cola intègre de la résine
de cannabis dans 7 % de sa production
mondiale
on essaie de plus en plus d'inclure des
sources de résine qui peuvent être en
droit du pétrole l'agencé canadienne
d'inspection des aliments autorise
l'intégration de plastique fabriqué à
base entre autres des moutons de blé de
maïs et autres plantes
mais est ce la solution carlao pas
attention à ne pas innover en produisant
plein de
de fruits de légumes dans nos champs qui
vont servir à créer des emballages au
lieu de nourrir les gens
oui c'est sûr que si on prend du maïs
qui est destinée à la consommation
humaine ou animale pour faire
un bioplastique c'est peut-être pas la
meilleure solution actuellement y
apparaît en beaucoup d'efforts qui se
font pour valoriser des résidus par
exemple de l'industrie agroalimentaire
qui vont permettre de faire des
biomatériaux qui pourraient être
utilisés en emballage
on remarque aussi des efforts à
concevoir de nouveaux contenants plus
écologiques comme ces barquettes évoque
disponible entre autres chez métro on
voit de plus en plus au niveau des
emballages d'essayer d'intégrer des
matières recyclées dans les emballages
sans compromettre la salubrité faudrait
tirer un peu sur l'industrie du
recyclage pour dire que les emballages
doivent contenir un certain pourcentage
de matières recyclées on pourra aller
jusqu'à 75 % de matières recyclées pour
être sûr qu'il ya une réelle économie
circulaire qui s'installe plusieurs
compagnies à travers le monde planches à
trouver des façons de mieux recycler ces
plastiques chine ou pauliste hiver a
enfin trouvé des débouchés pour les
fameux plastique numéro 6
une entreprise de terrebonne elle a
découvert un procédé novateur pour
redonner vie ou plastique pet et nous on
en prend le déchet dangereux mais à leur
président abbas et après ça on recombine
a fait du plastique neuf
une fois que ces refaite en plastique on
est capable de recycler infiniment qui
sont vos clients
on travaille avec nicolas et bien nasri
tout les gros joueurs au monde
daniel et son équipe verront leurs
technologies en opération dans des
chaînes de production d'ici 2 j'ai
commencé dans mon sous-sol chez moi il
ya trois ans et demi
où est-ce qu'on est rendu maintenant
mais on est vraiment juste à les débuts
de cette technologie là elle a la
puissance pourra vraiment changé le
monde changer le monde
en innovant en créant des plastiques
moins polluants en réduisant l'emballage
en utilisant des matières recyclables
voilà des pistes de solution à cette
guerre ou plastique est ce que ça prend
des instances gouvernementales pour
obliger tous les joueurs à changer leur
précisément la réglementation peut
amener les entreprises à accélérer un
petit peu leur processus d'innovation
des entreprises sont quand même très
consciente des enjeux qui sont là des
géants de l'alimentation se sont engagés
à n'utiliser que des emballages
réutilisables recyclables ou
compostables d'ici 2025
encore faut-il que ces objectifs soient
atteints puisque aucune loi ni aucune
réglementation ne les y oblige
[Musique]